il est temps à présent de retrouver
notre page était chaque jour cette
semaine nathanaël le maire et david
jouillat nous font découvrir des modes
de déplacement doux en touraine et
aujourd'hui on vous retrouve nathanaël
dans la vallée de l'indre vous étiez
accompagnés par des ânes aujourd'hui oui
je vous les présente d'ailleurs rina
sofia et rosalie alors ce sont des ânes
qui ici h hambourg se rendre sont
proposés à la promenade c'est à dire que
les touristes peuvent revenir et
emprunter pour une promenade de deux
heures annan qui peut à la fois porter
un sac voir un enfant et vous allez voir
dans le portage dans le reportage qui va
suivre que pour les enfants la présence
de l'âne sans change tout à la promenade
là on va reprendre le chemin de grande
randonnée ici le 46 on va remonter on va
aller jusqu'à la forêt toute l'étendue
marron là c'est la forêt c'est en
famille et avec un âne que virginie
ludovic zoé et leoni ont choisi de
découvrir la campagne lochoise dans la
vallée de l'indre la proposition de
promenade battait existe depuis peu au
delà de sa capacité à porter l'animal
est un compagnon appréciable avec
l'année va falloir être persuasif
utiliser d'autres modes de
fonctionnement pour faire avancer un
animal et c'est là où c'est intéressant
et où ça nous ça nous renvoie nous mêmes
en fait parce qu'il va falloir vraiment
aller chercher des choses marquées aussi
une fermeté ce que l'année il a besoin
de savoir qui conduit quand même aussi
mais pas forcément dans la domination
c'était très subtil ça peut être un
claquement de doigts ça peut être
voilà un encouragement une une flatterie
ou alors juste attendre cinq minutes
parce qu'il s'est passé quelque chose
lui il a besoin de cinq minutes pour
avancer et ça ça oblige à ralentir et à
pas maîtriser tous depuis toujours lan
accompagne l'homme dans ses périples
pour les touristes pas besoin de permis
spécial
il suffit d'être à l'écouté nokla l
écoute devant tu vas l écoute devant
derrière quand elle est très fâchée elle
fait comme ça et quand elle est super
bien cool elle et laisse comme ça elle
doit se repose mais là elle est très
intrigués par ce qui se passe devant
elle
un mât sofia sofia va accompagner notre
famille sur 6 km deux heures de balade
avec un âne une promenade mémorable
parce que c'était un choix de faire
cette activité parce que justement
c'était parce que c'était frais ni vial
ex ecover aux enfants léonie à quatre
ans pour l'instant c'est bien là est ce
que tu es bien c'était c'est quelque
chose qui adapte pour eux voilà s'ils
sont trop fatigués de pouvoir de marché
tout est prévu pour monter sur l'année
entre chemins champs et forêts lane se
révèle au bout du voyage
un vrai compagnon de route un compagnon
qui paraît comme ça au premier un visage
assez facile à emprunter pour pour une
promenade
nous sommes avec la propriétaire katia
villa alors est-ce que c'est aussi
facile on arrive en touriste on prend en
année on va se promener est-ce que c'est
aussi simple que ça bah oui parce que la
plupart des personnes qui viennent nous
voir n'ont jamais fait ce type
d'activités dont qu'ils arrivent on
prend à peu près à une demi heure trois
quart d'heure de temps pour faire
connaissance avec l'âne en prendre soin
le battait et puis expliquer un petit
peu le chemin aux enfants et aux parents
et ensuite je les accompagne un temps
pas tout le parcours mais un petit peu
pour leur expliquer comment ça va
fonctionner et c'est parti pour eux et
tout le monde revient ravit donc je
suppose que ça fonctionne alors quand on
nous dit tout le monde revient ravi en
fait qu'est-ce qu'il ya de deux
séduisants dans le fait d'utiliser un
âne dans une randonnée qu'on pourrait
faire simplement à pied
déjà les enfants voient pas le temps
passer quand il ya des animaux ni les
parents d'ailleurs ça permet également
des échanges et des interactions parce
que l'animal crée forcément des moments
inattendus au cours du voyage
donc les parents et les enfants voilà on
des grands moments des changes
et puis il y à aussi ce pas un peu qui
est comment dire le pas de l'âne et ça
apaise ça permet aussi une promenade
différentes
on est plus en proximité avec la nature
il me semble avec avec l'âne vous qu'est
ce qui vous a séduit pour vous avez 11
and proposé à la promenade qu'est ce qui
vous a intéressé pour monter ce qui est
quand même un produit touristique
alors moi dans ma démarche c'était à
faire le constat que j'avais fait c'est
qu'il manquait d'activités touristiques
pour les très jeunes enfants et et c'est
exactement ça parce que le public
principal que j'ai cédé ce sont des
enfants des familles avec des enfants
qui ont entre 2 et 5 6 ans donc voilà en
touraine on a plein de choses à proposer
ça c'est sûr j'en suis bien consciente
mais si on les jeunes enfants et pour
des projets de plein air très peu donc
celui là voilà il me semblait qu'il
manquait à la tour en bois pour vous
avoir suivi aujourd'hui je peux vous
dire que ce type de promenade même pour
les adultes c'est agréable et c'est vrai
que pour les enfants en cas de petite
fatigue ils peuvent aussi monter sur
l'année on a vu aujourd'hui que la
promenade de deux heures c'était c'était
très bien c'était vraiment un mode de
transport doux et je vous propose de
nous retrouver demain pour d'autres
projets de ce genre bah oui merci
beaucoup nathanaël le maire on vous
retrouve demain dès midi pour la suite
de ce périple entourage